this report I think is kind of
interesting this is from study finds.
org it says when tragic events happen no
matter how far away from us they are
it's hard not to pay attention many of
us empathize with the people in these
situations and wonder how we can get
involved or if there's anything we can
do to help over the past few years we've
borne witness to a series of pivotal
Global events from the co pandemic to
Russia's invasion of Ukraine as well as
many natural
disasters uh just when it seemed that
things could not get worse Hamas
launched an attack on Israel
um and uh but as the as the report
continues to explain citing various
different scientific uh supposed
authorities that all of this leads to
what they're calling compassion
fatigue compassion fatigue is a stress
response that results in feelings of
apathy or indifference towards those who
are suffering this phenomenon is
particularly common in Health Care
Health and Social Workers may be
particularly prone because the nature of
the work often means sharing the
emotional burden of your patience but
we're being told that compassion fatigue
is a
um widespread phenomenon now uh and what
they're saying is because so many
horrible things are happening in the
world and so people are fatigued and and
it's making you know it's it's having
the the reverse effect of making them
more indifferent to world events and you
know compassion fatigue sounds like the
kind of concept that I would make fun of
and maybe by All rights I should but I
will shock you and say that I think
there's some validity to this idea now I
think I'm not sure I would call it
compassion fatigue that's probably not
the phrase I would use to describe the
phenomenon but it is a real phenomenon
and it's a consequence of all of us
being plugged in and aware of everything
happening everywhere all the time and
not just aware of it but to be but to be
immersed in it and and uh you know it's
not even like maybe what it would have
been in the past if you pick up a
newspaper and you get a very small sort
of curated collection of all the things
that are happening in the world and then
you put the newspaper down you go about
your day now it's just a constant
onslaught of everything happening all
the time and um and it it's not just
articles but it's videos and it's images
and if there's some really horrible
thing that happen that we're all going
to see whether we want to see it or not
if you're on social media you're
scrolling along and then boom right in
front of your face you didn't even
choose to watch it you just saw someone
get shot or killed or blown up I mean um
this is what we're we're
all uh this is the situation we're all
in and it isn't natural and I I I don't
even think that we
quite uh
grasp just how unnatural all of this is
human beings are not meant to carry
around in our heads in our consciences
this
awareness of thousands of things
happening thousands of miles away from
us
um I think it has it has us totally
overwhelmed and numb it has our
priorities wildly out of
balance and the worst thing is that
we're all suffering from this right um
from this uh if we want to call it
compassion fatigue and yet and yet we
wield it against each other in in in
certain um opportune times like we all
understand what this is like and we all
know that you you can't like be
emotionally invested in everything now
we all know that and yet um if something
bad happens in the world and if you
don't appear to be immediately
devastated by it if you aren't
obsessively focused on it if you aren't
as angry and sad as you are supposed to
be then other people will go well why
don't you care about this what what
about this huh why aren't you talking
about this why don't you care about this
more why AR you focusing on this more
well I don't know maybe
because I'm a human being maybe because
I can't care care deeply about
everything happening in the world always
maybe I'm only emotionally capable of
being invested in a very limited number
of events at a
time maybe again because I'm a human
like you with profiling surveillance and
data harvesting there are lots of things
not to like about tech Giants but what
can you actually do about it when you
rely on so many of their products well
the good news is it doesn't take much
for you to take a stand for less than $7
a month you can join me and fight back
against big Tech by using expressvpn how
do you think big Tech compan make all
their money well uh by tracking your
searches video history and everything
you click on and then selling your
personal data expressvpn helps you
anonymize much of your online presence
by hiding your IP address a unique
identifier that every device has that
allows big Tech to match your activity
back to you that's why I use expressvpn
on all my devices to make it much more
difficult for them to exploit my data
for their own profits the best part is
how easy it is to use I just tap one
button on my phone or computer to turn
it on that's all it takes to keep people
out of my business so if you don't like
big Tech tracking you and and selling
your personal data for for a profit it's
time to fight back visit expressvpn.com
Walsh now to protect your online freedom
and privacy that's expressvpn.com Walsh
expressvpn.com
Walsh for most homeowners window
replacement is not something they've
done before and for many it isn't
something that they want to do but
rather something they have to do if
you've put off replacing windows in your
home because it's too expensive I have
great news you can now get a free inhome
window consultation and a free price
quote from Renewal by Anderson Renewal
by Anderson signature service is
committed to giving you the best
customer experience possible through the
perfect combination of the best people
in the industry a superior process and
an exclusive product right now Renewal
by Anderson is offering a free inhome or
virtual consultation on durable quality
affordable uh windows or patio doors for
Z down zero payments and zero interest
for a year Tex Walsh to 200 300 for your
free consultation to save $375 off every
window and $750 off every door these
savings won't last long so be sure to
check it out by texting wall to 200 300
that's Walsh to 200 300 texting privacy
policy terms conditions posted at text
plan. us texting enrolls for recurring
automated text marketing messages
message and data rates may apply reply
stop to opt out go to window appointment
now.com for full offer
details you know there was a massacre I
think in
uh I can't even remember where it was uh
there in Sudan just a few days ago
hundreds of innocent people butchered um
men women children
nobody's talking about that nobody is
talking about that nobody in this
country is talking about it or
pretending to care and I'm not talking
about it either this the first time you
heard it from
me um and you know what when I heard
about it I didn't I didn't shed a single
tear I didn't now not because I'm cruel
or callous I I recognize that it's a
terrible tragedy from an intellectual
like intellectually I care
intellectually I see it as a s I
recognize that I understand
it but but I simply cannot be distraught
and devastated by all tragedies that
occur everywhere because otherwise I
will be distraught and devastated all
the time with no break between one
tragedy to the next and that's just not
it's not even like when I say can't I
mean it's not just that it would be
difficult to operate that way I mean
literally can't the human mind is not
capable of
that neither is yours nobody
is and that's why we all typically
prioritize and Care the most
about the things that are closest to us
and so that that's the thing that
that um is the most frustrating is
that you know it's one thing to be like
constantly aware of every all the bad
things bad things bad things bad things
constantly always and we're it's and
it's we're surrounded by it all the time
it's one thing for that but
um it's another thing again when when
our natural human impulses and wiring is
used against us by other people who know
exactly what they're
doing and uh because this is how all
people operate
right you if there's something if
there's some tragedy like you you will
prioritize the things and Care the most
about the things that are happening
closest to
you um that's the way goes the things
that you are connected to those are the
things that you care the most
about um which is why let's say in your
community if there's if there's a a car
accident in your community and a child
is
killed you will probably if it's in your
community especially if it's someone
that you
know you will
feel much more emotionally uh devastated
by that than by a report of a massacre
of 500 people uh 5,000 miles away even
though the other thing is like
objectively worse more people died you
care more about the other thing not
because you're cruel not because you're
a sociopath but because you're a human
and you that's how we are meant to be is
you care about the things that are
closest to you everybody does and so if
there's
some if there's something happening far
away uh that you really care a lot about
it's only because you perceive yourself
as having some personal connection to
it that's that's why that's that's how
it's so selective you know we all care
about things closest to us and then when
it comes to like Global tragedies and
there's a never-ending supply of them
everyone's very selective about which
ones they say oh we should care about
well it's because if you perceive a a
personal connection to it that's why you
care about it and then you turn around
to other people who don't perceive that
personal connection and and you get
angry at them um one way or
another we all care primarily about the
things that are closest to us and that
is natural uh it's how it's supposed to
be um it's why like ultimately you know
one of the many reasons why probably the
internet and social media is a net well
not pro let me back up not probably the
internet social media definitely a net
negative for for mankind um it exists
and I believe that we I'm I'm here right
now so since it exists and it's not
going anywhere we should try to use it
as best we can for for good but best the
best thing would be if we could if I
could just snap my fingers and make it
all disappear I would because um one of
the problems with it is how it uh it
just works against our basic human
wiring um and it it it takes us away
from the immediate the like our
communities our families these are the
things we should we should care more
about those and if someone says well why
you only care you care more about that
then of course I care more about that
I'm supposed to that's the right
approach uh but it takes us out of that
and it kind of like we we only have a
certain amount of compassion that we're
capable of and it just sort of like
disperses it
everywhere and
uh to the point where it's sort of
dispersed into nothingness and I think
that's what's happening if You' like to
see what else I have to say you can
access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there godp speed